So, source working memory not contains all the things that we had in
the previous shot. Some of these are percepts. Some the things are the pitcher's
internal goals. Let us see how the contents of the working memory,
now invoke different kinds of knowledge from the long term memory.
So, let us imagine that the procedural part of source long term
memory contains the following rules. The procedural knowledge and
source long term memory is represented in the form of rules.
The system sometimes called production group. In fact,
the term production systems comes from the term production group. So, each rule
here is a production group. I've shown seven here, there could be more rules.
Once again, these production rules are captured in the procedural knowledge, and
soource long-term memory. Recall that one of the first things that the pitcher
had to decide was whether the pitcher should throw a pitch or walk the batter.
Therefore, we assume that there are some rules which allow the pitcher to make
a decision between these two choices. Thus there is a rule here. If the goal is
to escape, and I perceive two outs, and I perceive on the second, and
I perceive a runner on the second and I perceive no runner on the first base,
then I'm suggest a goal of intentionally walk batter. There is another rule.
The second rule says, if the goal is to escape, and I perceive two outs and
I perceive a runner on the first base. Or if perceived not out on the second, or
if perceived no runners,
then suggest the goal to get the batter out via pitching. And what might
happen if I pick the goal of intentionally walking the batter? The goal
is to intentionally walk the batter then suggest intentional walk operator. Now,
this intentional walk operator corresponds to some action available to all. And
similarly, the other rules. Let's consider one other rule, rule number seven.
If only one operator has been selected, then send the operator to
the motor system and add the pitch thrown to the state. So, there is
both now an action has been selected, and the action is going to be executed.
As well as the state of the working memory is going to be changed, so
it will say that now the pitch has been thrown. Before we go ahead, let me
summarize what we just learned. Source long term memory consists of various
kinds of knowledge. One kind of knowledge, the one that we are considering right
now is procedural knowledge. Procedural knowledge is about how to do something.
And so procedural knowledge is represented in the form of production rules.
Each production rule is, is of the form, if something then something.
There are antecedents and their consequence. These antecedents may be connected
through various kind of relationships, like and, and or. The consequence too
might be connected through various kind of relationships like and, and
or. So I may have if some antecedent is true, and some other,
other ante, antecedent is true, and so on, then do some consequent. Now that we
understand a little bit about the representation of production rules. What about
the content? What should be the content that we put into these production rules?
Earlier we had said that cognitive architectures are goal oriented. So
we'll expect goals to appear in some of the production rules. Indeed, they do.
R1, r2, r3, and so on. Earlier we had said that knowledge based
AI cognitive systems, use a lot of knowledge. And you can see how detailed and
specific this knowledge is. In fact, the knowledge is so detailed and
specific that in principle we can hope that as different percepts come from
the world, some rule is available that will be useful for that set of percepts.